uncharted 4 oh that's good practice I
know I we go and you're so good they
showed it twice yeah nice the first
minute or so I also the DualShock 4
sinking yes I look at this market for
five minutes see how many people we can
put on screen at the power of the
PlayStation they're always acting
natural all right now that's dying you
reckon they just roll tape then the
second time where I was like yeah our
mom I do a shark stock connector hook it
out fascinated bit what's that guy doing
with that pole over there to be fair
there's a lot of people on the screen
right now is a lot of dudes in that
market and so that demo proceeded
started off very uncharted feeling yeah
it's like the been in them is it sort of
uncharted 3 where you're playing is
young Nate and usually a market after
Sully and I'll tell you me that's what
kind of reminisce minding me of and then
you know the two of them get together
and form this formidable team they just
feel bad boys I love the destructibility
here it's like some y'all easy new
version of counter-strike like CS Italy
or something yeah chunks of stuff flying
all over the place a lot of stuff being
smashed around a lot of like just
objects loose in the environment that
you're kicking around this combat very
uncharted feeling as your sort of
battling through games looking gorgeous
but then a little bit later they hop
into a truck yeah they've never been
driving as I've been a driving sequence
in an uncharted before I'm sure there
must been in or at least jumped off
shooting from a jump from a jump on that
you achieve in on the desert and char
three I don't remember anything ever
ever drive I don't think that's a yeah
this is just like unshackling you from
kind of like the lead corridor kind of
style that they have had to like it
almost feels open wall that time yes
like it's just a little bit ambitious
like I didn't like it's not he could
have gone left her right there it's not
very obviously signposting where you
need to go next is kind of like I mean
they're doing it from through intuitive
design and that yeah but it's not
immediately apparent there's not a giant
arrow points and go this way is no
golden ledges yeah exactly no gorgeous
just like you could I mean hopefully
there's not a foul stay if he Chuck's
are right here and just get help or
something well they did like the
sort of action games they given you the
illusion of an object which is enough
you know and uncharted has certainly
done that to a great success in their
pet in their past I mean it's always
been a series that's been about creating
that that illusion of options you know
and that illusion of oh my god i just
picked this crazy path along the way
that was so great even though there's no
other way you could gone but they sell
it right they sell it well and they
certainly sell this well and we all just
started laughing delightedly as he's
just bombarding down rules and then like
a monster truck over a huge bunch of
parked cars I think the thing that I
like most about is up until now we've
seen quite a lot dark imagery and we've
had the guys from the last of us taking
over and being like art is going to be a
gritty and darker story about you know
Nate and his brother and this weird
history that they have together and him
abandoning his friend but it's good to
see that they still have the kind of
like Indiana Jones this is just crazy
fun romp kind of angle to it too nate is
Sully quipping their way through life
entirely graduations literally
everything around them it's just yeah it
just like the great one liners are still
there like what is it I I got it I got
it I don't got it yeah yeah hold on what
do you think I've been doing well chair
for the coat does he hit this goat I
look like you did the first time eiko is
running fast it was a little weird code
into motion over there per second get on
it no he talked i miss pinnacles
straight like a great okay oh that
wasn't really yeah and then yeah we're
gonna watch this for sure yeah there's
no way you can get this far no we don't
watch it is it's just closet terminator
three classic enjoy oh you think that
you've reached the kind of unique of
adrenaline rush they do is just do one
more thing yeah uncharted for a thief's
end wrapping up sony's e3 press
conference here at e3 2015
you